the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences invite you to be its guests at
the 36th annual Academy Awards
presentation much of the excitement at
every academy award presentations is
generated by the prominent arriving
guests tonight including many of your
screen papers
mr. Steve McQueen
lovely Julie Andrews Tuesday mr. Bobby
Darin pretty bride Sandra Dee
one of Hollywood's greats mr. David
Niven starring in the new action feature
and Nightrunner of vengo and this is
Patty Duke winner of the 1962 Supporting
Actress Award for Miracle Worker mr.
John Huston director more recently actor
this is Shirley Jones lovely Shirley
Joan
in case you were too high up to spot the
last freeway turnoff I'll tell you where
we are we're at the Santa Monica Civic
Auditorium and by pure coincidence
this is Oscar night the house is filling
up rapidly with producers directors
performers and members of the
international press corps you don't mind
being jostled I'll take you inside and
get you seated
yeah
that outer lobby is a regular obstacle
course TV cameras radio equipment light
platforms camera cables plus a few
people everybody is frantic the Academy
has a strict rule the doors closed at
6:45 sharp naturally most people start
for the theater at 6:40 at least a
hundred of those leave their tickets on
the front hall table and twenty women
have to find a second glove before they
can get out of the car good evening yeah
thank you hi Charlie
fine
an academy program weighs just about as
much as an average anvil it's printed on
heavy paper there are 27 categories and
five nominees in each category John
Wayne is the last man who was able to
hold up a program through the whole show
I don't know how that camera was angled
but I imagine it picked up some familiar
faces they're seated all over this huge
auditorium glamorous contestants the
standard props furs jewelry and
tranquilizers
this year's overture is a tribute to one
of the nation's all-time great
songwriters who is also the Academy's
present mr. Arthur free it's titled
fantasy on songs by Arthur freed and
natio her Brown the Academy Awards
orchestra with four-time the Academy
Award winner John Green conducting
magic time thank you but even the
overture that you've just heard so
brilliantly played by mr. green is a
collection of songs and medley with
lyrics by arthur free plus it's a
curious coincidence the mystery happens
to be the president of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences and
also sheer coincidence happens to be the
chairman of the committee to pick the
songs to be played on the super deck
it's another story
at any rate welcome this is the night
the night when the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences honors those
who have made outstanding contributions
to our industry in this past year by
arts and sciences I must say both
branches have been very very busy very
busy busy especially in Sciences there
has been one outstanding contribution as
we all know which has changed the entire
face of our industry what it is done to
the faces take the cigarette out of this
actually is what it has done and I don't
think there's any question but that this
will go down in history is the year that
the movies quit smoking and this has
wreaked havoc therein well actors are
standing around by the thousands were
twitching nervously with nothing to do
with their hands not knowing that this
has been going on ever since the time of
Shakespeare the importance that the
cigarette is a prop to an actor nobody
really realized if I may quote from
Henry the fourth part - he was found by
a mighty blow a Lucky Strike
all of us realized the number marvelous
romantic scenes that we no longer see
under standard gaze adoringly in the
eyes of your loved one take out a
cigarette and relight it
we pass it lovingly in tenderly and she
takes it and you play that scene now and
everybody in the audience turns says
he's trying to kill her he's trying to
start a killer
they both these advances have not been
precluded only the science we've taken a
giant step forward in the field of the
arts particularly in the vital area of
depravity pretty full on there for a
while there was nothing you couldn't do
on the screen there was nothing left a
censor until finally our British cousins
discovered that just eating plain simple
eating was very very sexy
immediately jumped on the bandwagon they
sprang into action we are revising our
production code I understand as of 5:30
this afternoon a man and a woman cannot
be together seen dining unless they are
married they both see on the floor and
at all times
you use the silverware be back in time
to time this evening with more bulletins
from the Academy in the meantime I would
like to start the program by introducing
the president of the Academy mr. Arthur
freed who will be played on
appropriately by a song selected
especially for this occasion by the
chairman of the committee to select the
song
on behalf of the Board of Governors of
Academy we welcome you to this the 36th
annual awards presentation the judgment
of 2500 Hollywood filmmakers will be
awaited with almost as much interest in
Tokyo as it will be an LM all our awards
now have become international in
tonight's nominees are here not only
from Hollywood
from all of them capitals of the world
and now I'd like you to meet mr. Bill
Miller of Price Waterhouse & Company the
ballots have been counted and the
results Aminu the mr. Miller Greenville
here's the certificate that Price
Waterhouse has tabulated the ballots of
the results are in the sealed envelope
thank you and now I turn you back to our
master of ceremonies for this evening
are charming censer mr. Jack Lemmon
well to present the first award of the
evening of a young man who was without
question not only one of the most
talented but most sought-after young
leading men in the industry but he
probably prefer to be known as the
fastest man on wheels ladies and
gentlemen Lyndon Johnson's driving
instructor mr. Steve McQueen
I told him not to put his hat over the
speedometer well that's half the kick
the nominees for the best achievement in
sound are Columbia studio sound
Department for Bye Bye Birdie Universal
City Studios sound Department for
captain Newman MD 20th Century Fox
studio sound Department and Tadeo sound
Department for Cleopatra metric golden
marathon department for How the West was
won
Samuel golden studio sound department
where it's a mad mad mad mad world and
the winner is
metro-goldwyn-mayer studio sound
department for How the West was won
thanks to you all from the metro Golda
Meir sound Department